bon je suggère qu'on commence par le
début
dites moi comment vous appelez j'en sais
rien [ __ ] c'est keith ballard vous
devez me laisser partir
je ne veux pas faire de mal à vous
semble a priori les ripoux les flics les
rues ils ont une autre façon de gérer
leurs investissements
je commence à croire que les miracles
existent tu devrais être mort à berchem
du bellay qui fait que je suis je vous
avais jamais vu lara gut si on se
connaît pas dis moi pourquoi je serais
allé me gravé son numéro de téléphone
son aura ok alors cette fois c'est
officiel tu me fout les jetons de n'a
rien contre à peine quelques pièces de
tout le puzzle t'as rien de plus mais
ils sont à l'abri
ton fils et afin de fêter la baille
s'est passé quelque chose peut donc
aller découvrir ton identité quoi
comment ça tu vois pour la section 6 3
comme moi voilà plus de deux ans qu'on
est en opération l'idée s'était placé un
homme au sein du gom dewinter
une terre s'est arrangé pour que tu
ailles à bangkok et dans sa tête c'était
un aller sans retour
c'est terminé je m'en charge ces poids
c'est toi qui m'a expliqué ses [ __ ]
de thaïlandais la mémoire qui touche et
il faut du temps pour s'en remettre
original pour le strict usage je suis
pas exactement comme les autres strip
teaseuse moi je porte un flingue là tu
m'a impressionné
alors aujourd'hui s'étend sur des
chances mais demain ce sera fini
soit tu perds la tête
ça aussi